Họng bị tám dở 3 mì phút ngày 20 mốt tháng mời người dân phát hiện ông Tơ Lâm Nhân
Bộ mi tám tuổi, chừng thuân à tuu một xa hủng sơn, đả nắng
Nằm bên về đường với nhiều vết thương í, so động vật hoang giá cắn
đã hình chương khiến về thuân sự kiểu và báo chính quyền
Ông Nhân, người dân top cơ tuu, cho biết bị gấu hoang tấn công trên đường từ giảy trở về
vân khu dừng giáp biệt giới lạc
Thượng tám ở nước đàn trường công an xa hủng sơn, thông tin công an xa
phối hợp ít tế đưa nạn nhân tới trạp ít tế xe cửu, ông bị giác môi giới
Bết thương dài ở cộ như không chúng độ mạnh, hiện tình tháo, chưa thể nói và cần chuyển chuyển chuyển chuyển
Nhà trước trách miến cáo người dân không đến gần khu dừng giáp lòng, chức năm 2018
Cuộc vực tây dàng tưởng sẻ ra vụ tương tự